[Music]
it's seven o'clock i'm dermott manahan
and you're watching sky news tonight and
a special question and answer program
about the cost of living on the day of
course that the chancellor announced
plans to spend 15 billion pounds to
alleviate the crisis
rishi sonic pledges support worth at
least 1 000 pounds for the poorest
households partly funded by a windfall
tax on energy firms
we have a responsibility
to help those who through no fault of
their own
are paying the highest price for the
inflation we face
but labour demands to know why it's
taken the chancellor so long to act to
help people
it shouldn't have taken a rocket
scientist to work out that this wouldn't
cut it and we pointed it out at the time
but that is just
[Music]
hey very good evening well coming up in
just a moment we'll be answering as many
of your questions as possible and there
are many of them on the cost of living
with our panel of experts but first let
me bring you a summary of the rest of
the day's main news
and the actor kevin spacey has been
charged with four counts of sexual
assault in the uk the crown prosecution
service says it relates to allegations
against three men
families of some of the children
murdered in the texas school shooting
have expressed anger about the police
response officials have admitted that
the gunman who killed 19 children was
barricaded inside a classroom in the
town of uvalde for almost an hour
the uk health security agency says that
it has bought more than 20 000 doses of
a smallpox vaccine to protect those
exposed to monkey pox a total of 90
cases have now been identified in the uk
with every nation now affected
okay uh let's concentrate then
on that top story and it was billed as a
plan to help alleviate the cost of
living crisis but in the event what the
chancellor announced today amounted to a
mini budget with 15 billion bands set
aside for a package of measures targeted
at the poorest 8 million households in
the uk
now pledging that we will get through
this rishi sunak confirmed that the
money would be partly paid for by a
temporary levy on oil and gas companies
a windfall tax confirming days of
speculation that the tax would be
implemented but the government faced
criticism from some conservative mps for
introducing a new tax on business while
three more back benchers called for the
prime minister to resign following the
findings of the su-grey report well
let's look then at today's announcements
in more detail
so as already mentioned the total
package consists of 15 billion pounds in
financial support
the energy bills discount due to come in
from october is being doubled from an
original 200 pounds to 400 pounds with
the requirement to pay it back being
scrapped altogether
then with a new one off 650 pounds cost
of living payment for the lowest income
households
a one-off payment of 300 pounds will be
provided to pensioners
and 150 pounds to people receiving
disability benefits
around five billion pounds will be
raised by a temporary windfall tax on
oil and gas firms here's our political
editor beth rigby
the focus now moving from one black door
to the next
away from the perils of partygate
towards the pounds in our pockets and
quite the reversal too after weeks of
stalling energy repayments now grants
instead
the tour is taxing business now against
a windfall tax now imposing it this a
chancellor wanting to make his mark on
the cost of living crisis
we need to make sure
that for those whom the struggle is too
hard
and for whom the risks are too great
they
are supported
this government will not sit idly by
whilst there is a risk that some in our
country
might be set so far back they might
never recover
this is simply
unacceptable
and we will never allow that to happen
we should not be ideological about this
we should be pragmatic that pragmatism
making way for a set of measures that
looks like an emergency budget in all
but name we are raising emergency funds
to help millions of the most vulnerable
families who are struggling right now
and all households will benefit from
universal support with energy bills of
400 pounds with not a penny to repay
in total
the measures i've announced today
provide support worth 15 billion pounds
combined with the plans we've already
announced
that means we are supporting families
with the cost of living with 37 billion
pounds or one and a half percent of gdp
plans plainly satisfying some yes yes
said the prime minister
genius he went on
but less pleasing for others targeted
help but universal support too taxing
energy companies to support those on
lower incomes not typical conservative
creed can i warn my writer my friend
that by
throwing red meat to socialists
by raising taxes on businesses and
telling them where to invest their money
is not the conservative way of
encouraging those who create our
prosperity and jobs to do just that
not an encouraging response but for the
opposition delight
the chancellor adopting a windfall tax
that they've been calling for for months
after today's announcement let there be
no doubt about who is winning the battle
of ideas in britain
party
today it feels like the chancellor has
finally realized the problems that the
country are facing
we first called for a windfall tax on
oil and gas producers nearly five months
ago
there's no doubt that parts of this
package are u-turns as the government
scrambles to try to deal with the pain
of rising energy bills after the
chancellor's march statement failed to
hit the mark but be in no doubt either
that this plan was brought forward by a
number 10 keen to turn the page on
partygate and try to regain some
political momentum but bigger than all
of that is this as one cabinet minister
put it to me you can't get on with the
business of government and policy when
you don't deal with the thing that's
keeping people awake at night
one cabinet minister telling me today he
appreciates issues and worries expressed
by colleagues recognizing too the costs
of today's policies i see their concerns
this is a balancing act
that it would be foolish of me to
pretend is easy to to get right said
jacob you said last week
against raiding the honey pot of
business with an oil and gas windfall
tax yes and what i was saying there is
that people need to understand that
there is not
a tax that you can take that is
economically cost free
it doesn't matter which tax it is it
will have an economic
consequence the afternoon brought the
chancellor a different kind of audience
on a visit to a b q in watford but the
future economic consequence of today's
emergency measures don't feel that we
can't get a grip of this because we can
not a picture the chancellor can yet
fully paint beth rigby sky news
westminster
well all day we've been asking for your
questions uh relating to rishis relax
yes if you can call it that we i say got
so many questions well with me to answer
them are miata fan boule ceo of the new
economics foundation personal finance
expert gemma godfrey they're here with
me in the studio and anna stevenson
senior welfare benefits specialist at
the charity turn to us
very welcome to you all thank you very
much indeed we have as i just said there
got loads and loads of questions so i'm
going to plow straight into them some of
them specific some of them a bit more
general so our first question is this
and i suppose it's one that so many
people have is the relief for energy
costs going to be
means tested well let me start with you
then anna um
is the answer to that i mean i'm
starting it off is is it kind of yes and
no
yes and no or a little bit of it depends
um there have been a few different
schemes announced today um the really
really big one is universal that's 400
pounds of winter energy bills for
everyone who's paying an energy bill so
that one's definitely not means tested
um we've got extra help for pensioners
that's not means tested that's based on
your age we've got extra help for
disabled people it's not means tested
but it's based on getting
non-means-tested disability benefits
things like attendance allowance or
personal independence payment
and then there's additional targeted
support 650 pound payment for people who
are on means-tested benefits but
technically that's not means tested it
will be 650 pounds regardless of whether
you're towards the top of the universal
credit income scale or towards the
bottom but it's based on getting one of
those means tested benefits
okay so that's clear and leads into the
next question i'm going to stay with you
on that and event uh so what are the
income thresholds for these payments and
and how are they being paid how will
people get them you're already telling
us that um when it comes to the we've
called it means tested but they're
shadowing the universal credit
thresholds
yes so these are based on you getting
one of the means tested benefits so
that's universal credit that's pension
credit
income support income related employment
and support allowance income related job
seekers allowance child tax credits
working tax credits this this big set of
means-tested benefits
now i can't give you an easy income
threshold because these benefits are
based on your circumstances what you can
really easily do is go to the turn
towards website and do a free benefit
calculator to check if you could be
getting any of these benefits they are
really under claimed especially pension
credit
so
there's not an income threshold but
they're based on these means tested
benefits
in terms of how they're being paid
they're going to be paid automatically
to people who are receiving those
benefits the assumption is that be paid
through the same means that you get your
benefit so if you get your benefit by a
direct transfer that will be how you get
it which most people do so i'll come
straight in right well let's concentrate
on our next question which is asking
about the 400 pounds that nearly all
households are getting and this question
asks
there you are when is the 400 pounds aid
likely to be given to customers
if it is in october as predicted how
will this help people that are already
in fuel debt now miata i mean because of
course you know the uh the cap already
went up substantially over 600 pounds in
april and so quite a long time to wait
well it is a long time away well the cap
went up by between 680 800 pounds we're
expecting it to go up by another 800
pounds in october so this 400 pounds
will help it's going to go to
energy companies that in that should
take it off your bill there's a bit of
trust there but they should take it off
your bill but in truth for a lot of
people it just won't be enough um it
will it will take the sting off but
you're still seeing a whopping 1 100
pounds that you're having to suck up
this year yeah on top of rising prices
for food and other things um
so
it helps but not as much as it does and
just what about this issue of the the
non-targeted nature of the of the 400
pounds i mean you know is that an
efficient use of funds which are pretty
sure um the short answer is no i think
they were thinking about the easiest and
quickest way so just give it to everyone
and give it to the energy companies and
you don't have to deal with the admin
my view is that they probably should
have raised the windfall tax by a bit
more and got a little bit more money and
then targeted those
in the middle that don't get benefits
but are really struggling that's just a
very very good point you're anticipating
our next question because so many
millions of people will be asking that
saying well okay you know i don't get
universal credit but boy are we
struggling here's the question uh what
help is available to people who aren't
entitled to universal credit anna
what help is available elsewhere i mean
do we do we know
i'm sorry gemma no it's fine it's fine
um so i mean this is the big problem
exactly with some of the government's
measures and we saw this when the
government came out with furlough which
was that people would fall through the
cracks and it's great to have and it's
incredibly important to support people
that are on benefits and it's easier to
identify them but you have a whole raft
of people that
are working really hard don't qualify
for the benefit support and they're not
going to be able to see as much support
as they need to if you also look at some
of the some of the measures that came
out certain you know council tax rebates
came in but again only for certain
households so the government's kind of
tried this act of you know give
everybody a certain level of support um
that isn't targeted enough and then
targeted level of support at the bottom
end and there are just millions of
people that are just not going to yeah
i mean but that that is the issue isn't
it where do you draw the lines and we've
got so many questions about that here's
uh here's our next one uh
again about lines i suppose if the
winter fuel allowance is currently
shared between two state pensioners
living together as a couple will the 300
pounds extra payment also be shared that
is one for you anna so two pensioners
living together um how is the money
divvied up and is it cut
uh yes from the information we've
received from the treasury so far it
looks like that 300 pound payment is for
a household not for an individual
okay very clear and that's all the
answer we need another question does
today's announcement mean the original
200 pounds help in october will not have
to be paid back through our energy bills
gemma yeah because people
you know people i suppose really didn't
quite understand that that 200 pounds
was going to be clawed back over what
was it was five years or something was
it wasn't five years well that was the
whole issue they were they were came out
and announced here you go you have 200
pounds and then the small print was you
have to pay it back and actually it
wasn't over a long enough period that we
think that the energy prices are going
to be able to adjust backwards so um so
they have come out today because of the
backlash really and they've said okay
they're going to double the allowance of
400 pounds and you don't have to pay it
back which otherwise would have been
madness the other thing wasn't it about
the about the 200 pounds was it was
about the household and the bill so if
you moved house if you were renting or
whatever or shared house well then you
know somebody else who moves in has to
pay it back it would have been an
administrative nightmare which would
have cost us millions yeah
okay um this windfall tax then on excess
profits as defined doesn't impact
households this is the question why
won't the energy cap be reinstated if
it's obvious the energy suppliers are
reaping the majority of the awards miata
what are your thoughts on that well so
in the government to be fair to the
government where the big excess profits
are being made are the energy generators
the people who are supplying us are sort
of retailers people like british grass
um edf have actually they are being
squeezed because they're the ones that
are sort of they have the cap that's
sort of bearing down um on
the costs that they can pass on so for
me what the government should have done
is say look let's properly tax those
that are making excess profits and let's
use that to cushion consumers and they
did that a little bit hence why we've
got the 400 but not enough properly
taxed so what would you like to have
seen well so the the numbers we were
talking about is tax 70
which they they ended up doing about 65
percent taxed 70 percent but without
this um tax deduction a lot of relief
a lot of relief that basically takes
most of it away that would have raised
about 13 billion and then use that 13
billion to help the squeeze middle but i
also think there's another thing that
they could have done which is one of the
reasons we're in this problem is because
a lot of suppliers also went bust and
there isn't enough competition in the
market so a lot of people have been
asking you know should they go around
and check for a better deal and there's
just not enough competition so actually
what you also need to see is some
support for smaller providers to bring
competition back into the market as well
okay got another quick one before we
need to take a break anna um short and
sweet if you can uh what help will there
be for people like me that can't go to
work due to illness will there be extra
help for the disabled community
there will yes so particularly if you're
getting personal independence payment
adult disability payment attendance
allowance disability a living allowance
um sorry i know it's a big long list but
you won't be getting all of them um if
you're getting any of those benefits
there'll be an extra 150 pound one-off
payment in december um it's likely you
may also be able to benefit from some of
the other schemes as well because all
these schemes are cumulative that's
important to remember so you'll get 150
pounds and you'll get the 400 pounds and
if you're on means tested benefits
you'll get 650 pounds and if you're a
pensioner the winter fuel allowance
yes yes exactly it'll all
round up to add extra extra extra
support for people who have these
multiple layers of vulnerability okay
that that's really useful advice thank
you all very much indeed so far but yeah
you're staying with me for quite a long
time we're going to take a short break
you're watching a question and answer
program about the cost of living so do
stay with us because we'll be tackling
more of your incredibly important
questions right after the break stay
with us
[Music]
[Music]
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
mandatory evacuation you must leave
i'm greg milam sky's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
it is almost impossible to predict where
these fires will go next
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those wins strong enough to bend and
twist metal
are you trying to run me over to fill it
no go away look like it sir
will you respond to those who made
accusations so philip can you go away
i've seen the dark side of america
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart of america's opioid
crisis
[Music]
i've seen heartbreaking human stories
there was a river of blood coming out of
the mosque that's a scene that you don't
forget
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
welcome back well joining me tonight to
answer your questions about the cost of
living our miata fanbooler ceo of the
new economics foundation personal
finance expert gemma godfrey and anna
stevenson senior welfare benefits
specialist at the charity turn to us so
we have all the the talented brains
trust here let's get into your questions
and
this one asks low-income families need
instant support how do you believe a
rise in winter fuel payments which won't
kick in until next year will help
struggling and vulnerable people miata
again we
address this slightly with the other
payments but it is it's the gap it's the
lag it is the lag um it is the lag and i
think a lot of people are already under
pressure uh to be fair some of it will
kick in early in the autumn but i think
where we will get to is that people get
to the back end of this year and they
will just be under phenomenal pressure
let's and the key thing to say is what
we're seeing at the moment is the impact
of rising price energy prices we know
that's going to have a knock-on effect
on everything else it's having a
knock-on effect on food it's having a
knock-on effect on everyday household
essentials and then you have the ukraine
impact so i think we're about to see
quite a hefty hit
this autumn winter and at the moment
they've taken the sting out the tail but
they haven't really resolved that issue
let's talk about that hefty hit because
our next question addresses that and no
i i did not know this this is a
householder who says that my energy
summary for the next 12 months forecast
that my energy bill will more than
double my goodness me what are the
government doing with the extra vat that
they will receive from us of course
gemini
they're raking in a lot of extra vat
because you know that hasn't gone or
does it five percent on energy
absolutely i think one of the things
that there was a lot of pressure for the
government to do was cut vat because if
there's a windfall tax on the energy
energy uh providers then likewise
they're getting a windfall from the vat
obviously the way the government's
positioning this is the v80 that they
make will then be funneled back into the
benefits and i think if you actually
look at everything they've done today
their total uh budget it brings it to 37
billion pounds that they've been using
to support families um so that's what
they're going to be doing but obviously
it's not as targeted as it should be
it's late in the game and at this point
you know if you have energy prices as
high as that one of the things we
haven't mentioned is debt if people fall
into debt then obviously you've got a
debt burden if interest rates go up as
they are then the price of having that
debt burden continues to go up and
people then fall further and further
under the cosh it applies to governments
as well doesn't it because the
government's debt burden their
repayments i mean they're eye-watering
at the moment well so the key thing to
say is not just vat the government has
had a massive boon in tax receipts
because of inflation so if we think back
to the spring statement the thing that
was very clear is the government was
getting more money than expected it was
paying down its deficit quicker than
expected it's due to make a surplus next
year so he had quite a lot of headroom
and for me i wanted to see more of that
headroom yes there was targeted support
for low-income families for example but
it's a one-off payment why are we not
rebuilding our social security safety
net the reason why a lot of people are
at the point where they're not eating or
heating is because we've hacked away at
benefits for about 10 years and so they
were already on the bread line and then
you chuck the shock and that's what
happened so that headroom
should have been used to build our
resilience not just for this winter but
for next year and the year after and
that's what he has the space to do with
that tax point and he hasn't chosen to
do that yeah here's the crystal ball
question who wants to stick their neck
out how
sorry what do you think will happen
to gas and electricity prices over the
next two years well miata you know we
mentioned the war in ukraine who knows
how long that will last but even with or
without it well energy just seems to be
going up and up yeah so all the
predictions are we're likely to see this
for another 12 to 18 months um and there
is you know part of the problem is there
are external forces but also our energy
market is quite broken uh so when you
look at wholesale prices they've
actually all dropped but a lot of the
energy providers bought in future
markets at high prices so consumers are
bearing the brunt of that i think it's
going to take us a couple of years for
this to shake out and i hope in that
time the government isn't just providing
short-term support but it's thinking
about how do we get this broken market
to actually work for consumers because
of the women in this market yeah anna
i've got a couple of questions for you
um let's have a look at this one i
support the government giving help to
those with benefits however
i am a single person who works and have
a lower income the cost of energy food
and fuel is pushing me into serious
financial crisis what help is there for
me
a single person who works and has a low
income and of course all those costs
going up what help
so this can be really challenging um
single people don't get the same work
allowances the same additional support
that you see in universal credit for
families and so that can mean that it is
much much harder to support the income
of single people
it is still worth a lot of people just
assume that they can't get benefits it
is still worth doing a benefit
calculator seeing if there is any help
they can get
um they will get this 400 pound off
their energy bills in the winter
it is still worth shopping around on
your other utilities to see if there is
any money you can save but
they are at the moment the group of
people who are the most challenging to
support and it's not just central
government that has funds isn't it local
authorities have been given relief funds
as well you can sometimes access them
they have yeah local authorities have
been given extra funding to provide
discretionary support people who are in
crisis but we haven't yet seen the terms
of these schemes what we have seen when
these
when there were equivalent schemes last
winter and the winter before was that
they tended to target families with
children and people with disabilities
because they tend to be the people who
get the very worst outcomes when things
go wrong and this council tax rebate
next question um the question is why is
the government just giving that on bands
a to d is there any chance of that being
expanded or extended
so this banzai today thing this is
exactly the problem that miata was
talking about earlier that it's really
really hard in our current data to
target middle income households it's
quite easy to identify the very lowest
income households but the government was
trying to provide semi-targeted support
towards middle-income households and
they went with council tax as the
mechanism to do that
there is discretionary funding that's
been given to councils for people who
are in higher council tax bands but who
didn't qualify for the um 150 pound
council tax rebate and who are in crisis
so if you're really struggling do
approach your council about that as in
so many cases in life that data really
matters the quality and the quantity um
last question to squeeze in in this
section gemma this is really
getting you to stick your neck out right
i heard you as you read it there it's
now a good time to get a mortgage who
knows i'm not going to say yes or no let
me explain what holds you to it how to
decide so first of all the context is is
that interest rates have been creeping
up and they're at one percent and yes
it's the highest of 13 years but it's
been an unprecedented period and
actually if you look at it in 1992
interest rates were over 10
so there's a huge amount that they could
continue to rise so the three things to
think about are um if you want to get a
mortgage i mean ultimately if you're
going to get a mortgage because you're
looking to buy property you know and
you'll need one to buy one but the three
things to think about are number one
about paying for the privilege of fixing
your mortgage right and to protect you
from higher interest rates um but you
will have to pay so to make sure that
that's actually worth your while
secondly consider when you'll want to
move because again a mortgage the term
of the mortgage there'll be early
repayments fees if you want to move
within that time and thirdly
affordability is a really key issue that
actually mortgage lenders are much more
focused on adding three percent to the
current in like their highest rate at
the moment and working out whether if
the rate was three percent higher
whether you could still afford it is
there also a guess though
for anyone buying into property now
about the possible impact of a recession
on house prices because you know whether
you get a good deal on your mortgage or
not if you're losing equity in your home
it doesn't really matter what rate
you're paying you you don't like it it's
not good for you i always say that
buying a house is more i mean it's a
it's it's not really we call it an
investment but it's really somewhere
that you live and if you really want to
make money out of out of property with
all the costs of moving and selling all
this stuff that actually it's more about
okay are you going to rent or is it
better value if you actually buy now
what can you afford how long do you want
to live there are you raising a family
all these other things i think come to
play very important okay uh taking a
break as i say you're watching the
special question and answer program
about the cost of living stay with us
next up amongst the questions we'll be
addressing the issue of whether all this
extra money in the economy will prove to
be inflationary stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back as you probably know by now
joining me tonight to answer your
questions about the cost of living our
miata fanboule ceo of the new economics
foundation personal finance expert gemma
godfrey and anna stevenson senior
welfare benefits specialist with the
charity turn to us we're going to turn
to more of your questions
this one concerning help for businesses
and through them help for employees is
there a way to support businesses by
giving employees a pay rise to help with
this increasing inflation what nine ten
percent at the moment uh miata well i
suppose there's the the minimum wage the
the living wage
there is there is the um national living
wage which the chancellor to be fair did
increase i think the key thing is
the living wage ought to reflect the
true cost of living and at the moment it
doesn't um so he increased it to about
nine nine pounds fifty um outside of
london uh and the we know that with
inflation that level should be much
higher um i do think there is a piece
around
where we build that it's tough for
businesses as well at the moment
but actually trying to get to people
where you're earning an income that
allows you to afford the cost of living
must be the objective in all of this and
just a big picture question mentioning
inflation in terms of the economy
overall now
i'm not an expert you are but isn't
putting lots of money into the economy
a risk when inflation is already rising
you know i mean people need the money to
spend but that then starts perhaps
pushing up inflation even more well
there is a risk but i think the key
thing is to remember what's driving
inflation so the big drivers of
inflation are imported it's kind of
global pressures energy supply chain etc
it's not the fact that the demand is
overheating the economy is overheating
there's lots of demand so actually we we
are on the cusp of recession which means
that demand is actually falling so
giving money to particularly to people
at the lower end who will spend it in
their local economies on essential
things i don't think it's going to spike
up inflation i think of anything it's
going to potentially help us stem the
worst impacts of recession so it's the
cause of inflation so it's really these
supply chain blockages at the moment
exactly thank you very much indeed for
that another question then i'll put this
one to you gemma my fixed rate deal with
scottish power finishes at the end of
the month going from get this 80 pounds
to 400 pounds multiple of five per month
what is the best thing to do i mean that
is an incredible increase what's your
advice i mean the real challenge is the
traditional advice would be shop around
a shop around try and get the best deal
but you can't at the moment because
actually a lot of suppliers went bust
and there isn't as much competition in
the market and also they're savvy
suppliers are savvy and you have to pay
for the privilege of fixing it at a
certain rate and the concern is is that
you may actually be paying too much um
at the moment in time because there's so
little choice out there people are so
fearful so actually it's some in some
respects some of the best advice is
actually wait and see which is a
horrible thing to say but really i think
there are so many families out there
that are struggling that are doing what
they can that putting pressure on saying
that there may be a better deal out
there is honestly so i mean you know do
you really have to take the money the
government's giving you and cross your
fingers and hope okay the price cap we
know is going up again in october then
when it's reviewed by
april 2023 that it starts to dip that's
all you can do well the problem is what
are the alternatives to that so it is
about making sure that you're getting
the right government support but
absolutely with the fact that the energy
cap is bound to go up energy suppliers
know that and therefore there's going to
be no fixed rate that will protect you
from that it is a very tough time okay
next question this one again about
pensioners what happened
to the triple lot for pensioners have
the government gone back on their
promise well anna i know a bit about
that well um yeah a bit uh tell us more
so the triple lock is a policy that um
guaranteed that pensions would go up by
at least
certain averages so um
there were three different rules and it
would go up by the lowest of them
the government has slightly abandoned
its promise on one of those because one
of those was average earnings and when
average earnings went very peculiar
during the pandemic the
government took the decision that they
would not be operating pensions in line
with average earnings
for a bit um the other issue is that
they have gone up in line with inflation
the trouble is that the rules by which
uh benefits and pensions are operated in
line with inflation it uses the
inflation rate in september to set the
amount they'll go up in april and of
course this year we saw inflation jump
enormously between september and april
and so that
um
increase the matched inflation back in
september by april was doing nothing and
by this winter we'll be doing absolutely
nothing um
and so the hope had been and had been a
lot of calls on the chancellor to make
an emergency up rating of benefits in
line with current inflation
uh the chancellor has not chosen to do
that and has chosen instead to use these
multiple different one-off payments
okay i see what you mean yes so they
could fast forward that but it doesn't
seem they are going to at the moment
more on energy costs and this about the
green levy within everyone's bills
the question is why can't this be
removed or at least reduced miata i mean
that's not just then about the money
that's about that the long term and
ultimately about the climate crisis
so it's a false economy because we have
to remember what this is paying for it's
paying for things like energy efficiency
which ironically is a thing that will
get down the cost of bills
for the long term it's also paying for
you know different types of kind of
renewables and that transition that we
need to make which again will help with
our security so getting rid of it is the
wrong temporarily though just about what
i do think the government should do is
take it off bills and the way it is and
puts it into general taxation because
it's a far more progressive way to do it
at the moment people at the bottom end
will pay more because they tend to pay
their energy bills tend to be a bigger
chunk of their income so i'm actually
all for removing it from levies it was
never for me a good way to do it can i
throw in then you know what about vat as
well you know that was meant to be that
was meant to be a brexit bonus not
allowed to do it under the eu this the
government can now do it but it hasn't
it hasn't done it but to be fair to them
v you know if you
removing vat would be about 100 100 odd
quid so in the grand scale of the
support that people need it probably is
sort of tinkering around the margins
and it isn't targeted so actually trying
to get to
cash payments for that middle is a far
better way to do it okay here's another
specific question but it does concern
the green ambitions the green necessity
for us all um why is hmrc not increase
the pence per mile for company car
drivers of electric cars the price cap
went up 50 percent on electric yet the
rate i can claim from my employer is
still only 5p a mile and who knows about
this gemma i mean you know there's
basically a bigger gap growing up again
in this area and i think this is a
fantastic question and obviously it
doesn't have an easy answer because why
the answer is that the government should
have been able to um make sure that
people that are deciding to to make
greener decisions are going to be better
for our economy and our on move to net
zero and having more renewable sources
of energy and less reliance and lower
energy bills people are able to do that
and helping us should get more support
and they're not and and that's really
and my big concern is is that again it's
like when full taxes on oil and gas
producers but they'll give them tax
relief what about all the other
alternatives that will make our supply
much stronger okay there are always
consequences aren't there um oh now
we've got a couple of minutes left so
let's get a couple more questions in
anna um try this for size shouldn't the
energy providers be reducing the cost on
pre-pay meters or apply credits for
people because prepay meters i mean
awfully
often it's the people who can least
afford it on prepaid meters and they're
paying higher rates
yeah um there is a higher energy price
cap for prepay customers the
justification for that has been that it
costs a little bit more to run the
infrastructure but this is a really
major problem that disproportionately
affects the lowest income households
it is very very important that they are
considered very carefully through this
winter because what happens
is that they just self-disconnect this
is the the mild term that gets applied
to it what that means is they don't have
any money to put in the meter and so
they just sit there in the cold in the
dark
and it ends up being somewhat invisible
in a way that um whereas you know
people people who pre-pay who pay with
um who get energy bills
they
can run up debt and still stay connected
to their electricity for quite a long
time whereas pre-pay meters the whole
point is that you can't but that causes
immense suffering to people on the
lowest incomes so it is really important
to make sure that these people are
protected through this winter yeah off
gems should do something about that
certainly um let's get one last in
before
our last break why is our government
making energy prices so high when other
countries in europe haven't seen the
same increases
miata well i suppose is that all about
sources of supply and storage
well so that that's a million dollar
question and i think it comes back to
the market um and i think it comes back
to the fact that the market isn't
working so if you look across to france
there they've got a public sector
provider um edf it's owned
by citizens and the governments
basically say you take the hit you take
the hit and actually the the risers
we've seen of about four percent
compared to what we're seeing here um so
different countries have different ways
in which they're supplying energy i
think the way that we have it is very
very broken and consumers have long paid
the price of that and they're paying the
price again and so in all of this there
is a big reform story when we get onto
the other side of this it's like how do
you break up that market and by the way
use the opportunities of bringing in
more renewables
to diversify that market to build up our
security and i would say have more of
that market owned by people like me and
you through cooperatives through
community um owned energy in a way
that's far more democratic and that
works in our interests rather than the
interests of those so general in a way
we in this country got the worst of all
worlds you know we had you know
multiplicity of providers as you
described earlier lots of them have gone
bust which leads us to the pickle
wherein would it be better you not only
out of there in the end well let's get
back to to a big people-owned supplier
we can look after the prices ourselves
we just multiple people in prison yeah
we need to have multiple dynamics and i
think that's the problem there's not
much that we can do to be able to help
bring more security to our energy
markets
good good break coming up um you're
watching a special question and answer
program about the cost of living uh do
stay with us after the break we're going
to be asking about any plans to help
first-time buyer statements
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
look at that sheet of flavor and it's
moving this way
and over there is dover we track the
changes happening to our world right now
i think it's a procession of the taliban
there they are right here would you as
prime minister be able to look them in
the face let's have a look at both of
those two things i just want to say
thank you for having the courage to
speak to us we do genuinely believe in
what we do to show the truth
i thought there was an astonishing story
there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back joining me tonight to
answer your questions about the cost of
living crisis are you know them all by
now a panel of experts they really are
experts so let's uh rather than me
introducing them again let's get some
more questions in because we have had so
many from you this is very short gemma
are there any plans to help first-time
buyers well there are already quite a
few schemes around aren't they i mean
there are already so in terms of is that
any new news the answer is no well what
are the existing ones talk to us i mean
well you have you have things like um
you had license you know lifetime isis
the ability to be able to save and if
you save um for a certain number of
years then obviously the government will
then provide you a certain level of
savings to match that the amount that
you've saved to put towards a deposit
and if you don't use that then it would
go towards a pension so been a few
things out there but i think the big
challenge for first-time buyers is first
of all is the fact that it's
a bigger deposit is now needed that a
lot of mortgage providers are actually
getting a little bit more savvy and the
affordability level is getting higher
and higher also the thing that has
changed as well as there has been a
period where the average cost of a
mortgage per month was cheaper than rent
and actually for the first time that's
now reversed so you know and again
interest rates are going up so i think
there's about three quarters of um
people that are on mortgages and haven't
fixed them you know this is a real issue
for people in the market at the moment
do you think though if the housing
market
starts to stall or shows the appearance
of doing that then the government might
bring in you know stat duty holidays
again or something like that i mean it's
a very easy lever for them to pull and
it's something they've done before
because i think the big cohort that
we're talking about now are the first
time buyers because of course people are
already in the property market well then
they'll benefit yes they may sell lower
but they'll also buy lower but i think
if there's a problem with uh the
property market stagnating and they need
to keep that going then that's something
that government let's talk uh now a bit
more about the targeting of this money
and uh
it's very straightforward question why
not contribute to a minimum wage
increase in
anna what are your thoughts
about that well
that really does help people in work who
just don't earn very much
it does but
the people who are the most vulnerable
to rising energy bills are pensioners
and people who are disabled and can't
work and an increase in minimum wage
wouldn't do anything to help them
okay miata you know i've seen i mean we
talked about the living wage the minimum
wage yeah so look in the end the
priority has to be those at the sharp
end of it but i think there are many
people on minimum wage who will also be
on universal credit um and will benefit
but you know there is a piece in all of
this about how we get raises to rise to
keep up with the cost of living
particularly at the bottom end and we
haven't got that right yet yeah and
isn't also the issue is about looking at
it long term some a lot of the time it's
about let's make sure that i mean a lot
of employers are under a lot of pressure
and i think also what we want to do is
try and stimulate the economy create
more job creation and you know certain
measures that might put them under
pressure to make make people redundant
because they can't afford them anymore i
think would be around they've already
had that insurance increase as well um
which seems to be being
overlooked um right long-term plan well
this is a good question is there any
sign of a long-term plan in this
announcement it'll help this winter no
doubt but isn't this just a sticking
plaster when we need stitches or as some
in government say when we need surgery
um miata long-term plan yeah we there's
no long-term plan in sight this is a
sticking plaster intervention which by
the way we needed a bit of sticking
plaster because it was so dire and it
was completely frustrating that the
chancellor moved as slowly as he did but
this gets us through the autumn
and beyond that not much else which is
why for me there should have been a
measure that was focused on bolstering
social security because we build that
resilience in the long term and we're
still waiting for that we needed to
seize things around energy efficiency
great homes upgrade imagine if we had a
national effort that said we're going to
insulate millions of homes over the
course of the next three years to bear
down on bills and then you move to
reform agenda and say look how do we get
wages up how do we get markets that you
know should be working for people not
working for people and there was none of
that so they've done enough
to help people in the short term
to live another day but they've not now
strategy
different perspectives i know from you
all on all of this staying with this
question anna what's your take on that
does it seem you know more or less
reactive rather than proactive no
evidence of a really detailed plan
yeah i mean it's positive that the
chancellor has recognized that the
social security system is a useful way
of targeting support to the lowest
income households but we have seen 10
years of benefit freezes and changes in
welfare policy that have just eaten and
eaten away at the financial resilience
of households and so now we're in a
situation where we lurch from crisis to
crisis we had covert we had emergency
measures put in and then we had
inflation we had emergency measures
within and then they weren't enough we
had some more emergency measures within
and this lurching from crisis crisis is
no good for the economy it's no good for
the country it's no good for the lowest
income people it just doesn't work
we need a welfare benefit system that
enables people to live and thrive and
participate fully in society
anna do you detect strategy here
or reaction well i think
absolutely it's reactive and i think one
of the other things is if you look at
the reasons why we've got higher
inflation it's also because of supply
chain issues you had brexit you've had
people because of covert going back to
other countries you've got more
restriction around free workforces there
are all these other dynamics that are in
play that and none of them you know we
talk about it's like it's like if
somebody's ill and we're only looking at
the symptoms we're not looking at the
cause and yes we need to prop up people
but what are we doing to actually help
stem the problem so that in a couple of
years time that these things can
readjust and i can't see any strategy
there but of course there is so much
uncertainty out there to to be fair to
anyone trying to come up with long-term
plans and uh
this is one of the the major challenges
well not just for for europe certainly
for ukraine but for the entire world um
if the war in ukraine ends will the cost
of living decrease again how long would
it take to feel
an impact well you know who knows but
miata what what's the feeling
will the cost of living decrease if we
can end that conflict if um well
the russians can be removed from ukraine
that's our hope but i think the key
point to say is that it will mean it
doesn't get worse so the cost of living
crisis was there even before ukraine and
there was a consequence of brexit i know
we're not allowed to talk about it
anymore but it's a consequence of brexit
it was a consequence of supply
bottlenecks coming out of the pandemic
some of which still haven't gone away
and it was a consequence of supply
pressures here you know we don't have an
energy
enough energy security in this country
so there were all these fundamental
problems anyway and then you threw in
the war in ukraine so i think we haven't
fully felt the impact of the warning we
can we're starting to feel it on things
like food prices and energy on the
margins but it could get worse so for me
it just means it doesn't get worse okay
worse before it gets better and we don't
know when that might happen last
question really interesting to get all
your takes on that have been fairly
brief because we're nearly out of time
are these policies just delaying an
inevitable recession oh
gemma i mean the the challenge that we
have is that a lot of families are
struggling and they're fighting a war on
multiple fronts and that i think is
that's why uh otherwise we would be
heading towards a recession so for
example you've got food prices going up
you've got travel prices going up it's
it's costing more to put a roof over
your family's heads as well as energy
keeping them warm and i think having all
of those battles um is putting on us on
a path there unless we can do something
to be able to actually stem the rising
cost of living across all these
different markets and anna does this
feel a bit like i mean for different
reasons though a bit like 2008 2009
where we're on a cliff edge
i can't really answer that but what i
can say is that is absolutely vital that
we make sure that the very poorest are
protected because we are
a compassionate caring country we do not
want to see children going to school
hungry we do not want to see old people
dying of the cold in their homes and so
we have to make sure that no matter what
happens the very poorest people are
protected well said we'll end it on
those words really good hearing that
thank you all very much indeed anna
stevenson really good hearing from you
gemma godfrey lovely having you here
miata van boule thank you so so much for
allowing us to access the brain cells
really have benefited an awful lot of
news you can use information you can use
there and you are watching sky news
tonight
coming up at eight o'clock uh we'll be
bringing more details about the politics
and the economics behind the
chancellor's announcement as he set out
his 15 billion plan to try to alleviate
the cost of living crisis we'll have all
the details of the announcement coming
up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you